chaos and confusion that's how one
neighbor described the scene on this
Suburban Street in the small hours of
this morning guardi Irish police were
alerted to a violent incident at a house
in the Dublin suburb of tala at around
12 30 a.m they arrived to a horrific
scene with several young casualties
believed to have been stabbed and an
active suspect
members of the Irish police are not
routinely armed so the specialist unit
the armed support unit was called in to
assist residents here spoke of hearing
several loud bangs as members of that
unit employed less than lethal devices
to subdue a suspect a man in his 20s and
arrest him here at the scene
there were three fatalities from the
attack eighteen-year-old Lisa cash and
two of her younger siblings twins
Christy and Chelsea Corley just eight
years old
another boy age 14 sustained
non-life-threatening injuries and the
severely traumatized mother was also
treated in hospital
on a personal level I reacted with Chuck
because this really is a shocking
really sad event and over here in
rossfield you can get that sense you
know people are standing behind our
doors they don't really want to talk
about it people are genuinely shocked
the manager of the local community
center says it's opened its doors to try
and support those who knew the victims a
lot of children are obviously
heartbroken at the loss of their friends
the cattle is on and the children are
coming in having a cup of tea having a
cherish and doing a little bit of
artwork
um and I suppose themed around
remembering their friends and we're just
here to listen and to be here as a
shoulder for anybody who needs it
experienced police officers were said to
be shaken at the scene in a statement
the guardi described the attack as a
violent challenging and traumatic
incident and said that the force has put
in place welfare supports for and will
continue to support all members who
attended this incident
guardi are holding the suspect at the
local station in tala they say they're
not looking for any other suspect in the
violent deaths of the three siblings
Stephen Murphy Sky News in Dublin